>> Laura: I'M LAURA INGRAHAM.
THIS IS "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE"
FROM WASHINGTON ON EDGE TONIGHT.
NOW, I'M GOING TO SAY THIS VERY
BLUNTLY.
WITH THEIR REFUSAL TO
FORTHRIGHTLY UNEQUIVOCALLY
CONDEMN THESE TERRORISTIC
TACTICS OF THEIR ACTIVIST
DEMOCRAT BASE, THE DEMOCRATS,
THE WHITE HOUSE, THEY'RE PUTTING
THE LIVES OF THE SUPREME COURT
JUSTICES IN JEOPARDY.
YES.
I MEAN IT, IN JEOPARDY.
NOW, A PARTY THAT SPENT THE PAST
16 MONTHS BRANDING THE GOP AS A
BUNCH OF INSURRECTIONISTS,
THEY'RE CARRYING OUT BY PROXY AN
INSURRECTION OF THEIR OWN
AGAINST THE FEDERAL JUDICIARY.
>> WE HAVE TO BE A MENACE TO OUR
ENEMIES.
THAT'S ANYBODY THAT IS ATTACKING
OUR REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM.
WE WILL NOT TURN BACK.
WE ARE WEARY.
WE ARE MAD AS HELL.
>> WE'VE HEARD ENOUGH.
>> Laura: OF COURSE THE
CRITICISMS OF THE OPINION ARE
THE IT'S HONEST CONSTITUTIONALLY
AND FRAUDULENT FACTUALLY.
THE ABORTION ISSUE IS RETURNED
TO THE STATES.
WE TALKED ABOUT THIS THE LAST
FEW NIGHTSES.
THAT IS WHERE THE VOTERS OF
THOSE STATES WILL DETERMINE THE
OUTCOME FOR ABORTION.
MIGHT BE REGULATED, MIGHT BE
OUTLAWED OR ALLOWED IN CERTAIN
CASES, MIGHT BE BANNED.
IT'S NOT A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
COAST TO COAST.
THE LEFT DOESN'T WANT THE VOTERS
TO HAVE A SAY AND THEY DON'T
CARE ABOUT FACTS OR PRINCIPLES.
FOR THEM, THAT LEAK OF THE DRAFT
OPINION ITSELF ORCHESTRATED AND
DISSEMINATED AS IT WAS, IT'S
MEANT TO TERRORIZE.
NOT TO INFLUENCE.
THINK ABOUT THIS.
WHY WOULD SOMEONE LEAK A
THREE--MONTH-OLD DRAFT OPINION
THAT WAS IN SOME FORM OR ANOTHER
COMING OUT IN JUNE ANYWAY?
TONIGHT THOUGH GIVEN EVERYTHING
I'VE SEEN, EVERYTHING I KNOW
ABOUT THE COURT AND ITS INNER
WORKINGS FROM THE TIME I
CLERKED, I'M DOING TO SAY I
BELIEVE THIS LEAK WAS DONE WITH
THE GOAL OF STOKING VIOLENCE
AGAINST THE CONSERVATIVE
JUSTICES PRIMARILY ON THE COURT.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE GOAL TO
FORCE A CHANGE IN THE COURT I
MAKEUP BEFORE THE NOVEMBER
ELECTION.
SOUNDS NEFARIOUS.
SOUNDS LIKE A TOTALLY HORRIFYING
PROSPECT.
THOSE THAT BELIEVE THAT
DISMEMBERING THIRD TRIMESTER
BABIES IS SOMEHOW A SACRED RIGHT
PROTECTED IN THE CONSTITUTION?
COULD THOSE PEOPLE VERY WELL BE
CAPABLE OF RATIONALIZING OTHER
INSIDIOUS ACTS?
NOW WHY ARE AREN'T POLITICIANS
IN BOTH PARTIES SPEAK OUT WHAT
IS AN OBVIOUS EFFORT TO
INTERFERE WITH OR INTIMIDATE THE
JUDICIAL PROCESS?
NOW, REMEMBER WHAT BIDEN
PROMISED US ON HIS INAUGURATION
DAY.
>> TODAY ON THIS JANUARY DAY, MY
WHOLE SOUL IS IN THIS BRINGING
AMERICA TOGETHER, UNITING OUR
PEOPLE, UNITING OUR NATION.
WE CAN TREAT EACH OTHER WITH
DIGNITY AND RESPECT.
WE CAN JOIN FORCES, STOP THE
SHOUTING AND LOWER THE
TEMPERATURE.
>> Laura: DID HE SEE WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN FRONT OF THE COURT
OR IN NEW YORK?
SEE ANY OF THAT OR JUST TUNED
OUT?
WHERE ARE BIDEN'S CALMING WORDS
NOW?
>> YOU THINK THE PROGRESSIVE
ACTIVISTS THAT ARE PLANNING
PROTESTS OUTSIDE OF THE
JUSTICES' HOUSES ARE EXTREME?
>> PEACEFUL PROTESTS?
NO.
PEACEFUL PROTEST IS NOT EXTREME.
>> THIS ACTIVIST POSTED A MAP
WITH THE HOME ADDRESSES OF THE
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES.
IS THAT THE KIND OF THE THING
THE PRESIDENT WANTS TO HELP YOUR
SIDE MAKE THEIR POINT?
>> THE PRESIDENT'S VIEW IS
THERE'S A LOT OF PASSION A LOT
OF FEAR, A LOT OF SADNESS FROM
MANY, MANY PEOPLE ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY ABOUT WHAT THEY SAW IN
THAT LEAKED DOCUMENT.
WE OBVIOUSLY WANT PEOPLE'S
PRIVACY TO BE RESPECTED.
>> Laura: THAT'S IT?
NOTHING ABOUT GOING TO PEOPLE'S
HOMES, WE WANT THEIR PRIVACY
RESPECTED?
SPELL IT OUT FOR US WHAT IS
GOING ON?
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND HIS PARTY
HAVE WHIPPED UP THE UGLIEST
RADICALS IN THEIR BASE.
THEY GIVE LIP SERVICE TO
PRIVACY.
OH, PLEASE.
AS WE REPORTED LAST NIGHT, THE
CONSERVATIVE JUSTICES HOMES,
LOCATIONS, HAVE BEEN SHARED
ONLINE.
PETER DOOCY REFERENCED THAT.
NOW THEY'RE RECEIVING PERSONAL
PHONE CALL THREATS.
JUSTICE ALITO, THE AUTHOR OF THE
OPINION, CANCELLED A SCHEDULED
APPEARANCE THURSDAY IN NASHVILLE
AT THE FIFTH CIRCUIT JUDICIAL
CONFERENCE.
HE SHOULD HAVE GONE.
YOU CAN'T GIVE IN TO THESE
THUGS.
JUSTICE THOMAS SPOKE TODAY AT
THE 11th CIRCUIT JUDICIAL
CONFERENCE.
FRIENDS THERE TOLD ME THAT HE
WAS UNBOWED AND AS FRIENDLY AS
ALWAYS TO ALL WHO APPROACHED
HIM.
BUT NEVERTHELESS, THE RISK IS
REAL TO THE JUSTICES' SAFETY
ACCORDING TO ONE SENATOR IT'S
BEEN REPORTED.
SO IF ANYTHING SHOULD HAPPEN TO
ANY OF THE JUSTICES OR THEIR
FAMILY MEMBERS, THE BLOOD, THE
SUFFERING, THE PAIN WILL BE ON
THE HANDS OF THE WHITE HOUSE AND
ALL OF THE SENATORS AND PRO
ABORTION FANATICS THAT WHIPPED
AMERICAS UP IN THIS FRENZY OR
FALSE